hi I'm Paul hi Quyen I'm with honey love
org I'm one of the directors and I'm
going to show you how to make honey from
my backyard so I'm with honey love org
we're an urban beekeeping nonprofit and
what we do is we educate the public that
honeybees are safe we mentor people to
become beekeepers
and so we're basically the voice of the
bees what does a beekeeper mean well it
means you have to go out and buy a bee
suit you get the gloves you get the hive
tool you get the bee brush and you get a
smoker those are the tools that you need
to become a beekeeper the reason I use
smoke is it masks the smell of the
pheromones of bees when bees actually
sting they give off a pheromone that
smells like rotten banana so when a bee
stings you and it gives off that
pheromone it gives off a signal to all
the other bees to go attack that area so
it's an alarm and what we're doing is
we're masking the alarm and when you
smoke them they think the house is on
fire and they're gonna go and they're
gonna start drinking honey and their
bellies get full and they can't stink so
they're gonna be focused on getting the
honey and drinking the honey opposed to
bothering you being a beekeeper is
actually just managing the growth of the
hive so all you have to do is make sure
the bees have enough room to grow and
that's the secret and as they grow you
add another box and another box honey is
be food and you don't want to take their
food from them unless it's an excess so
what I tend to do is I'll go into my
hives in my backyard and I'll take one
or two or three frames out of the hive
so I'm not depleting to their whole
honey supply when you become a beekeeper
what you have to do is every four to six
weeks you open up the hive and you do
hive inspections and what I'm looking
for growth I'm looking for the brood the
baby bees and the larvae you want to
make sure that the queen is laying eggs
and if the queen is laying eggs
means there's a healthy queen the hives
growing and what I'm looking for is the
honey are they producing honey are they
making honey they're called worker bees
for a reason right
they work and work and work and they
produce one bee only produces 1/12 of a
teaspoon they'll fly back and forth
anywhere from three to five miles to get
a nectar first they go get the nectar
and they stored in their honey stomachs
they have these little pouches called
honey stomachs and they come back to the
hive and they regurgitate it from there
these little straw
you know tongues that they have and they
give it to the other bees and they take
that nectar and they put it into this
cells and what they do is they fan and
evaporate the water content and then
you're left with honey so that's how
honey is made so I open up the hive and
when I'm taking it looking for the honey
I need to get the bees off of it so I'm
gonna lift up the hives and I can do one
of two things I can you know kind of
give it a good shake which you know
works really well and they come off but
if they're if they're really hanging on
you can get a bee brush and just brush
them lightly off and they'll fall off
once we get the the frames inside the
kitchen what we do is we're gonna put
them on a cookie sheet so you're not
making a mess and you're gonna take a
knife and you're gonna just cut the wax
and the frame all the way around you're
gonna just draw a line around the square
frame you're gonna cut cut it out and
you're left with a big block of honey
and wax and from there I'm gonna take a
fork and I'm just gonna decap it right
I'm just gonna take that first layer off
and what that does is it kind of opens
it up and it makes it easier for it to
crush and strain so when I'm in there
it'll just make it easier for me so
we're just gonna kind of rake a fork
over the top of it open them up both
sides cut it up throw it into your bowl
and then all I'm gonna do is just crush
and strain it I'm just gonna turn it
turn turn turn
crush crush crush and once I do that it
almost liquefies and once it liquefies
you're ready to filter the or the honey
out of the wax and you do that by the
weight the weight of the honey after
it's strained at the very bottom you
have a little you know a little spout
and all you do is just put your jar
there and we're gonna fill it up with
honey and that's it it goes from the
hive crush and strain to the jar
this is how honey is made in my backyard
[Music]
you